hannover namens luca meine lieben
freunde herzlich willkommen wie heute
ist mittlerweile schon dritten von
sydney war ich den nicht mehr so könnt
ihr mich einfach meine begrüße maria i
betreffen stolperte sportler auf
tollpatschige tiere und eine panne jagt
die nächste viel spaß weil einzig wahren
bungie also meine lieben freunde
herzlich willkommen wir heute ist
mittlerweile schon dritten zeitkontrolle
die ersten beiden teile habe ich
zusammen mit abbildungen schenks gemacht
hat schenkt es heute allerdings leider
verhindert ist haben wir ihnen durch
sandra ersetzt und cola oder geht so ich
würde sagen
april starten wieder bei mir wohl so ich
hab hier im grundspiel armband mit hätte
ist um heil ich sage hier zum abend auch
kat in etwa armreif schmuck ist bei
jedem egal was sie sagen aber es hätte
okay ich hätte es nicht durchgehend okay
dann sag ich
[Musik]
wasser ich weiß überhaupt nichts
nein kann ich pflanze deutsche sprache
schwere sprache
ich sage wächst
[Musik]
kirche gebetshaus
es gibt nicht die steuer gehabt haben
muss zeigt auch mal sagen ich hab mal
sagt noch nicht mal geht ja ich gehe
heute beten beisteuern
jesus hat könnte man glauben
ich sage haus gottes habe ich ja schon
mal von ein dass gottes gotteshaus nur
für ende obwohl man auch auf gottes hat
dieses yoga ist okay gut monopol
das nicht alkohol alkohol ist das tool
ist schwer sagt ja was mal durchgehen
ist das spiel die hose oh mein gott wie
komme ich durch zufall marco prozentiges
gedrängt was durch einen brach auf
gymnasien alter softgetränk man sagt ja
auch so
[Musik]
doch für mich getränken aber jetzt
gerade situation haben dass ich nur
einen minuspunkt haare sind allerdings
zwei ein update 2 würde ich sagen gehe
ich kurz raus und ihr beiden entscheide
das unter euch
kamera kein englisches wort video
apparat police alte aufnahmen gut aber
ich hab noch einige reflex ja ich werde
mich gehabt da verlieren
sandra führt deswegen fotoapparat
wahrscheinlich sind deine eltern treten
mit dir ich muss auch ganz kosten 43
selbst auslösendes gerät einen daumen
hoch
da schon wieder vorbei
[Musik]